du willst, dass ich das lese das dokument
hatte das unbekannte bekannte gezeigt betta donna
straßenbahnen gefüttert fühl dich ruhig fasano beobachte bella
ryan thema was du weißt es gibt
bekannte bekannte es gibt bekannte unbekannte
es gibt unbekannte unbekannte aber es gibt
auch unbekannte bekannte una nina hagen
ashpit errol  Morris-Team per E-Mail an
American Fatigue Hongs Minister Agra
begann in Statistik und Zep spuckt
Apulian auf den Kopf Spa-Führungskollegen
nach Spean Warum die
Besessenheit vom Irak und Saddam
werden Sie dieses Wort Besessenheit lieben? Ich kann
das Leuchten in Ihrem Gesicht sehen, wenn Sie es
sagen  Nun, ich bin eine obsessive Person, oder du,
ich bin es nicht, und ich bin cool, gemessen mürrisch,
fett, vez de Guiche despierta, nachdem ich Dora
konfrontiert hatte, lud sie viele Dafa-Gibbons ein,
die unbekannten, bekannten Titanen, vollbusige Brights,
Boston, es ist nicht so, als ob du es nicht
wüsstest  von Möglichkeiten, aber Sie neigen dazu,
einige Möglichkeiten mehr zu bevorzugen als
andere
nna Politiker Jacques Demers Ich bin über
die neuen Akte von Tausenden, wenn ein Politiker
Saddam Hussein Osama bin Laden den Krieg gegen den Terror erklärt,
so in Gefahr geschlossen,
dass jeder Mitarbeiter Osama davonkommt
und eine Verwirrung in den Menschen einsetzt, die
glauben, dass Saddam  war mit
al-qaida verbunden und mit 911 gut, ich glaube
nicht Gustav Fähnrich wird angeklickt antworten
angiogramme gefüttert blima verpfändet
sous-vide leisten einen skandal auf einem buch
ipod Guantanamo lärmt wegen einer
Thornton-Geldstrafe herum, oh, keine bedeutung, blute
was alles  Diese sogenannten Folter-
Memos, nun, es gab ein oder zwei oder
drei, ich weiß die Anzahl nicht, aber es
gab nicht alle diese sogenannten Folter-Memos,
sie wurden fälschlicherweise als Folter-
Memos bezeichnet, und sie kamen nicht
per se aus der Buschverwaltung  Sie kamen aus
dem US-Justizministerium. Ich habe noch
nie so viele Fehlinformationen gesehen, die
über einem
Ort kommuniziert wurden, als der Fall über Guantanamo Bay, die
Schlüssel-TV-Sensation, verdammtes Vivian Donald
Rumsfeld-Albumblut in th war  Das Unbekannte ist
oft bekannt, wenn Sie jemanden
in einem großen Publikum fragen, wie viele Menschen Ihrer
Meinung nach in Guantánamo Waterboarding waren,
und die Leute strecken ihre Hände hoch, und
jemand wird sagen, Hunderte, die
Antwort ist niemand